je commence à être menacée au tout début
de l'émission lorsqu'on a commencé le 14
octobre cette émission face à l'info
science et news avec eric zemmour oui et
où je m'étais préparé psychologiquement
à recevoir un tombeau d' insulte donc je
m'étais vraiment préparé j'ai pris des
des community managers pour mes réseaux
sociaux et cetera et pour bien tout
gérer et
et effectivement j'ai reçu des menaces
par courrier je m'attendais pas aux
courriers met donc je les voyais je
déchirais je suis chez moi et à ses news
chez vous aussi c'est chez moi je lui ai
4 à ses news c'est encore plus à
faire flipper chez vous ah oui courir
sur moi comme un cri aux suis pas envie
de rentrer dans les détails
[Rires]
non mais j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans
les détails mais c'étaient les le plus
virulent que j'avais que j'avais reçu à
l'époque en octobre 2009 c'était con con
je conte voulais mélanger tout
simplement gentil mot voilà donc nous
emm a eu peur vous avez eu en avait une
petite fille aussi que oui alors sur le
coup sur le coup
j'ai mis ça dans le lot des critiques de
départ et je me suis pas rendu compte et
après plus les jours passent et plus les
semaines passent et plus je trouvais
tellement injuste
en fait c'est menacer puis mais plus les
gens passaient plus les semaines passent
et plus aussi
gp si ma carapace une chose est claire
c'est qu'à partir du moment où je les
dis publiquement que j'ai eu des menaces
elles ont arrêté elles se sont arrêtées
pendant pratiquement deux ans et 100 %
du courrier quand je reçois du courrier
postal mais sans pense en ce sens que
des courriers élogieux
allée des gens qui sont vraiment à fans
de l'émission jusqu'à ce message et la
personne m'a aussi appelé m'a envoyé des
sms à la première est
ben je ne sais pas comment ça se fait
mais non mais la terre vous appelez
personnel la personne qui vous qui vous
menacent elles vous appelez vous a dit
quoi j'ai pas décrocher donc après la
personne m'envoyer des sms mais de quoi
j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans les
détails si ça si vous permettez mon cher
jours qu'un jour
je n'en ai dit non mais sans détails
sais quoi parce que c'est important
qu'on sache mais un peu de malades ou de
style moi y'a pas là parce que c'est ce
que vous avez donné dans justement
christine qui est la question que je me
pose c'est
c'est donc son numéro à la personne pas
non vous avez donc son numéro un oui oui
et c'est pour ça que personnellement je
n'ai pas voulu porter plainte moi
honnêtement c'est c'est vrai je trouve
que je suis j'ai pas envie de me nîmes a
victimisé ni quoi que ce soit mais c'est
l'avocat qui s'en occupe il s'en est
occupé aujourd'hui il a déposé la
plainte aujourd'hui on va savoir c'est
vraiment téléphoniques et plainte contre
pour pour menaces de mort et
et je remercie d'ailleurs arash
derambarsh qu'on connaît et
et voilà donc je suis contente qu'il ait
pris les choses en main pour que je ne
puisse pas moi non plus on encore aller
devant les policiers passer une heure ou
deux pour voir donc pardonnez moi mais
ça me gêne aussi c'est l'attention sur
moi je trouvais dans ma vie ne vaut pas
la plus la vie de quelqu'un d'autre fine
et non le régime quoi je comprends tout
à fait c'est juste pour que puisse
comprendre ce que c'est juste moi je
pourrais je demander à christine parce
que je sais que je vende ses blessés
c'est extrêmement violents ce qui a reçu
christine cristina les continuent elles
et elles baissent plus jamais les bras
elle fait son émission tous les soirs
elle est incroyable dans son émission
mais c'est vrai que christine
je sais que vous avez vous vécu vivez
des moments difficiles parce que vous
êtes même sous protection je crois oui
depuis plusieurs mois
ces deux baby sitter en permanence il
vaut mieux en série rentrée mais je ne
ce qui est anormal mon cher un cyril
c'est que au
nom de coin aujourd'hui on doit être en
tant que journaliste avec deux baby
sitter qui vous accompagne toute la
journée au nom de quoi en tant que
journaliste on doit recevoir des menaces
de mort au nom de quoi je veux dire
comme si le fait de ne pas prendre
position
dans sur mes plateaux
c'est déjà une erreur comme si
aujourd'hui on vend composition je ne
sais pas mais plus on propositions où on
est menacé - proposition plus on est
menacé jamais on me prendra à témoin
d'avoir pris position pour quelques
penser que ce soit